so as your grandson seen the film yet
not yet no but he's seen the character
yeah and he's schooling me on the sonic
game oh you know cuz I never really you
know was into video games in a major way
so my life I feel this - Mario Brothers
so insanely that we had to actually take
the game away from her cuz it was like
cracked her love her literally I put it
on a shelf and said you know a monster
broken ya know kind of thing I came in
here and stepped on it you didn't play
any video games I played video games and
that's not true I've hid I'm a big pong
fan no but you know I am trying to keep
up and it's hilarious because my
grandson we were playing the other day
and he is just wiping the floor with me
in every respect and and I I get angry
and I put money in the swear jar and and
stuff like that and then I said to him I
finally got fed up because he likes the
trash talk me too I love him totally and
he's 9 and it's really scary and he said
I said you know next time you come back
here I will practiced and I'm gonna kick
your butt
like that and he said yeah if you go
back and get born again and I'm start
playing at the age of 2 what happened
here yeah it's pretty fun so wait you
you when you spoke about your daughter
and she actually we don't like that it
was comfy on my lumbar but we were talk
about your daughter just a second and
she's open for me like you know send you
her regards because she loved you so
daughter though well done she was so
cool and so
[Applause]
oh no she's smart she's been very good
counsel you know that's the thing that
happens it switches around you know you
help them through their tough times and
stuff and then sooner or later they turn
around and that you you're you're going
how do you know that yeah you know they
see you like you don't see yourself yeah
like my five-year-old Oh call me out on
something I'll be like oh that was real
yeah there's no filter
I don't care yeah they don't care I mean
I swear I'm a good mommy he's hilarious
though she told me the other day that
she's never seen a scary moment in a
movie and I said what are you talking
about you've never seen a scary moment
in a movie and she told me that every
horror movie she's ever watched she does
this when the scary part comes can you
get a close-up of my face just come
right in don't be afraid so whatever she
sees the scary part in the movie she
does this so the Mert movie becomes a
blur of a bunch of different images and
stuff like that so now when I watch
horror movies with her it's like so Axew
excellent excellent really good jump
scare they're reminded that really the
visuals is sound and the sound gets I
don't watch her I'm like peace out oh no
it's horror movies for me are really not
that impactful because it can never
match what's going on in here would
sleep if I could match what's going on
in here that's the left side is pursuing
the right side of an axe
oh that's my immune system anyway I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this